So I just watched Casey,
nice guide to instagram.
Video is right here if you guys want to
check it out.
And I,
I couldn't agree more.
Instagram has become,
you know,
my favorite social media platform to,
for all the reasons you know that he
mentioned that it's pure,
simple unsullied by the information dump
of facebook.
He just said dumb,
but more than being just unsettled by
the volume of facebook.
It's also free of the performances of
facebook too.
I've talked about our social media
personalities before in Vlog Twenty,
70.
Click it right here.
If you want to check that out.
For instagram,
I personally follow three simple rules,
three simple donuts and I,
I've told these to my friends so I might
as well tell them to you to rule number
one,
don't take pictures of yourself.
Rule number two,
don't take pictures of food.
What could possibly be interesting?
How about your beef?
Boring,
young.
What could be interesting about your
pasta sauce?
A doubt,
your pepper Jack Cheese fondue,
and rule number three,
and I think this is,
this is the hardest one to follow.
Don't take pictures that show you
clearly having fun.
Now I still use facebook to be sure,
but I've moved more toward instagram
because facebook sort of became this
virtual,
keeping up with the Joneses where
instead of getting more and more stuff,
it was trying to look more and more
cool.
I think of the instagram camera as my.
I,
I use it to share what I see so that
people,
my friends can experience what I'm
experiencing.
Do I sometimes break those rules above?
I mean no.
Never,
never.
Do I ever break those rules?
Of course I do,
but they're in my head nonetheless.
If you have your own instagram rules,
leave them in the comments below and
don't be afraid of those people who like
to say,
I don't like to live by any rules and
you can tell me what to do because that
person always talks like this and they
have to live with that.
He's a nice that you live in New York
City,
right?
Let's collaborate.